the white house has signaled that it
might ban the
chinese app tick tock and since i am not
a 15 year old girl
i do not know very much about tick tock
i have not seen very many tick tocks
i don't want my brain to melt and turn
to mush so my producer ben
has decided to play a few of these for
me
because i want to be able to make an
informed judgment on whether or not the
white house
should ban tick-tock let's take it away
as me i didn't i didn't put that on tick
tock we put that up
real quick caleb
uh that's almost certainly the best
content on the
entire platform and i'm pleased that
that caleb lawson can get some
some views on my behalf but watch out
buddy because xi jinping is getting all
of your information
when you use tiktok let's go to the
second one next person who has the sheer
nerve
the shear entitled caucasity to say all
lives matter
i'ma stab you i'mma stab you and while
you're struggling and bleeding out i'ma
show you my paper cut
and say my cut matters too
trump supporters just took my job away
from me
yeah so really sad obviously our heart
bleeds for this harvard student
who used caucasity whiteness
as an insult and who who was making uh
either a joke or a threat or a threat
and a joke or whatever what's so funny
though
she loses her job because of this and
then immediately she makes another tick
tock like the
the you you think you would have learned
the lesson if you've gone to harvard
maybe not though i think there's a
lesson in this for all of us though
which is that the more information we
give to china the more all of our jobs
are going to be taken away and maybe
more than that okay next one up
grandma destroys trump if you've been
paying attention to the news you know
that donald trump is planning on holding
his first
political rally post-quarantine on june
19th in tulsa oklahoma now if you don't
know why that's a big deal i want you to
google two phrases
juneteenth and black wall street you'll
find out why people are really upset
about this i wanted to slap in the face
to the black community
somebody on another tick tock post
commented that he was offering two free
tickets on his
campaign website to go to this rally so
i recommend all of those of us that want
to see this 19 000 seat auditorium
barely filled or completely empty
go reserve tickets now and leave him
standing there alone on the stage what
do you say
i love it when middle-aged white women
tell me what is very offensive for the
black community i think that basically
describes the democratic party
and the far left is very very white
people
pretending to be offended on behalf of
black people and other racial minorities
this makes sense to me though that that
this is where they would go because
obviously republicans dominate
conservatives dominate on most social
media platforms
youtube twitter obviously with trump
facebook that's where they live
and so the chinese spy app would would
be the social media platform that the
left would use
to organize i guess there's an update on
this which is from new york times
tick-tock grandma
who helped tank trump rally now works
for biden
yeah biden needs all the help he can get
thought oh my
with that young whiffer snapper over
there she clearly knows something about
the internet so
welcome to the campaign i i wonder if
maybe she'll quarantine in the basement
with joe
it'll be a pretty uh pretty easy
campaign to run because no one has to
leave their house
let's move on to the next
section of tick tock videos these would
be
the tick tock videos that reveal the
honesty of the left so i've heard
that this is one of the reasons to allow
tick tock to exist
is because the left outs itself as being
so
anti-american first one up a democrat
cry for help democrat please don't make
me vote for don't
please don't make me vote for joe biden
please don't make me vote for joe biden
i don't want to vote for joe biden that
one i like
that one's pretty good because no one
seriously believes that leftist
activists are thrilled with joe biden
the best endorsement of him they can
muster is that he's
not all there mentally so they can just
bully him into doing whatever they want
but that's good
i like airing that out a little bit
pitting the bernie bros against the
biden
whoever the biden nobody's because
nobody supports joe biden
that's not bad next one up get pumped
for the polls
if joe biden wants my vote then he
better pick animal crossing as his vice
president joe biden 2020
i can't wait for him to try to appeal
the young voters by
hitting the woe on ellen or some [ __ ] oh
god
oh that's actually going to happen god i
can't i can't
as soon as he gets on tick tock and you
know he's going to
i'm joining isis and i and not and i
name that even if joe biden picked
the cure for covid as his running mate i
would still be at the polls like
okay i just can't wait for the moment
he's debating trump and he accidentally
calls
trump senator standers and then tries to
fix it by saying something like
hey jack i wish if he loses to trump
which like
i don't want to hear that as
progressive's fault okay because because
this shit's on you guys
anyway vote blue no matter who
that was pretty good that's probably my
favorite what i've seen so far
i i guess it must be that the left
thinks that only lefties are on tick
tock which frankly might well be the
case i don't i haven't seen like a lot
of conservative videos on tick tock
so they they're willing to air this
dirty laundry among
each other you know they put on a good
good face they put on you know a stiff
upper lip when they're talking in the
mainstream media to conservatives but
how much they like biden but
they they don't really seem to believe
that when you talk to them honestly
next one is joe biden's most effective
slogan for 2020
introducing the settle for biden t-shirt
this 100
cotton t-shirt will let people know that
you'll vote for an old
out-of-touch democrat in november but
you won't be happy about it
settle for biden because it could be
worse it could be better
but it could be worse yeah that's fine
but it's not really in the spirit of
tick-tock like
the point of tik-tok is these like fast
cuts and it's really loose and authentic
and it kind of makes your brain melt
that was just like a produced youtube
video from the mid-2000s
that one not making me too excited for
it there's one here that seems to be
fairly honest
that is called the progressive anthem
i'd like to hear the progressive anthem
i'm ashamed to be
an american where not all folks are free
and i won't forget the enslaved who died
and built this place for free so i
proudly
lift up all the folks who are still
oppressed today
cause there ain't no doubt this ain't
our land
trump and the usa are there
any actual black people on tick tock is
that
every video i've seen on tick tock is
basically just
white liberals usually pretending to be
offended on behalf of black people but i
see no evidence so far
that there is a single actual black
person
on tick tock and not very diverse
okay not not living up to those those
high liberal ideals
next section is the educational
side of tick tock so apparently people
god help us as a country
people are getting their information
like political
social information from tick tock let's
see what we can learn
okay i don't have a lot of time but
basically i follow this guy on twitter
and if you want to know his name i'll
leave it in the comments
but basically he's a neurologist and he
studies dementia and he
is pretty convinced that trump has
dementia and it's not because of his
like
erratic behavior whatever but basically
this is a list
of dementia symptoms but what to me is
the most damning is the way trump stands
so in the top left there is a picture of
from a 1930s medical journal of how
people with dementia stand
now obviously these pictures are kind of
scary because he stands just like that
and of course these pictures could be
photoshopped but i've met trump in
person
and he absolutely stands like this in
this gal's defense
it seems to me she has at least as much
credibility as dr fauci at this point
like i don't think what she's saying is
true or anything
but when you look at the current medical
establishment that's been completely
wrong about every aspect of coronavirus
and still with a straight face tells us
what to do
because zillions of people are going to
die i got to tell you she is just as
good i think it now that we
we get those press conferences with dr
fauci and dr scarf i think we should
bring that gal up there too
and really round out the uh the
destruction of credibility on the
national stage next one up
is the most damning attack on trump
yet he has no lips how will he get a
kiss kiss
very ugly no kiss for him
i guess that one's pretty funny he said
with the music and the weird warping and
that
that voice it does sound to me like what
hell
sounds like and tick tock kind of looks
like what hell looks like
and there's seem it's just seems like
maybe there's
a little bit of a demonic element here
this is making me less likely to want to
keep tick tock
next one up take that trump supporter
if y'all think trump is so bad name five
bad things he's done
and away we go he started the birth
movement he obstructed congress and told
the subordinates to lie to congress he
solicited the help of a foreign
government to win an election
he called john mccain not a war hero
because he was captured and five
he separated children from their parents
as a matter of immigration policy
there you go so only one of those is
actually true right he did say the thing
about john mccain and they feuded for
the rest of john mccain's life
but all the other ones just aren't true
the near the nearest one to being true
is the immigration thing but that
immigration policy was set during the
clinton administration so
not not very credible stuff on the
educational side of tick tock here i
suppose as we might expect
next one up she showed us i bought this
big bag of gibbets for my crocs
and um this guy came in it so
i'm just gonna um
thank you so throwing away the american
flag
and police cars again i kind of like
that that one probably fits more under
the leftists being honest about who they
are
section of it and i do like that i love
it when the left shows us who they are
i hate seeing christopher columbus
statues and george washington statues
torn down
but i do love it when the people who are
doing that show their faces so we know
not to vote for the people that they
support that's that's pretty good that's
not too bad
next up proof trump needs to ban tick
tock here's the proof
anybody else get a little hot in here
this is uh whoa
okay glad my wife didn't catch me
looking at that one on gosh nothing
nothing like putting on a little orange
and building the wall gets me uh
gets me excited for the rest of the tick
tock videos final one up is
uh oh finally final one up is crews and
knolls
get destroyed with facts and logic
i mean we were told first do not wear
masks do not buy masks masks are not
effective they're actually harmful
then we were told we all have to buy
masks the reason why the general public
was not
advised to buy masks is because health
professionals needed those masks
first it was not because wearing a mask
did not work for example remember the
toilet paper shortages
remember how nobody couldn't find toilet
paper anymore
well same thing with the mask right we
were concerned that health professionals
wouldn't be able to find
masks because y'all don't would buy too
much
but now we're good and in fact we're a
little too good now y'all know
not buying masks at all what the [ __ ]
so that also is not true but he actually
makes a pretty
interesting point the point just
undercuts his argument so what we were
told is that the masks are not effective
and actually there's a lot of
evidence today on the cdc website that
shows that those regular cloth masks are
not
very effective at preventing the spread
of the virus or preventing infection
however the point he makes is a pretty
good point which is
look it's at least a plausible point his
point is early on we needed masks for
medical professionals so
the public health officials lied to
everybody and told them the masks aren't
effective
so that people wouldn't buy them so we
could give them to the health
professionals because the health
professionals lives matter much more
than your puny peasant life
that's his argument the trouble with
that argument
is if you're already granting that the
public health professionals lied at the
beginning
then they're liars and we have no reason
to believe them now we actually can't
believe them now
that's what happens when when you
tarnish your credibility especially in
something like
public health or in journalism so
i've got to say of all of those my
favorite hmm
this is a really tough one i guess my
favorite would be
the the guy complaining about having to
vote for joe biden i felt his was the
most clever
the most thorough i felt like i was
looking into the the
innermost heart of a leftist so that was
really beautiful that was that was high
art
uh i would like to know your favorite i
think it's probably that one though it
might be it might be me getting
destroyed with facts and logic who knows
that's what tick-tock is
and uh last question should president
trump ban
tick-tock absolutely
that thing is not only bad from a
national security standpoint
it's not only bad from a spiritual
standpoint
but it is definitely bad from an
intellectual standpoint
it will melt your brain proceed
with caution and get rid of tick tock
[Music]
you